[Applause]
all right hi everyone I'm so excited to
be starting off to guess Coffey you by
talking to you about how to use Chrome
developer tools to hack your way into
concerts now these subtitles talk is
please don't actually use this
information I'm not here to tell you to
do anything that's literally illegal or
to break any user agreements we're here
for the education and so do as I say and
not as I am still saying so I'm gonna
tell you about a story this all really
did happen to me last year I was really
excited about Taylor Swift I wanted to
get in tickets to a concert and I
learned so much about web development on
the way to doing that I built us a small
web app for the purpose of this talk and
I will be recreating the kinds of
interactions that I saw when I was
investigating her web site so we have
this website website called Swifty's
it's selling tickets to Taylor sauce
concert and they want to give tickets to
the the most dedicated fans of Taylor
Swift and they're measuring your
dedication by how many times you've
watched her music video so the more you
watched her music video the more you
will have priority in line at the end no
seriously
so we want to convince Swifties that
we've watched the music video more times
than we really have you know it's like
four minutes long it's awesome awesome
not look what you made me do is not like
the greatest music video to be honest
like I'm sorry but I really thought
Taylor stuff isn't watching so
so space on with your story this is the
what we're gonna be doing for the next
30 minutes IRA I wrote this slide before
I realized that I actually cannot see
you all very much but we will be using
the browser a lot in this talk I've
tried to make the font as big as
possible
if you can't see please like do just
call out I don't want to want you to
miss the content just because you can't
see we can make the font bigger if
someone near you is straining in they're
too shy you know just call it for them I
will not be mad so we've got Swifties
here it's a very pared down web site I
also realized that Taylor Swift is a lot
more cool than I am so I swapped out the
music video for a timer so that you
could all taste it's gonna talk but you
know it will work even if you replace it
with a four-minute video and I suppose
it says one view it should say zero
views that's fine starting the lifetime
off great so we can play a video oh my
god that's like the biggest hurdle here
so you know we got this video we watched
the whole thing this is the only time
I'm gonna watch the whole video and I
couldn't think of any funny jokes to
tell during this time but eventually
I'll end and I can stop being awkward
yeah so we have two two views now and so
we just wanted to get that number as big
as possible so the first thing I started
thinking when I was debugging this
website was like how do I just make this
video faster I know that I can come over
here and click on speed and click it - -
and that will make the video faster but
what if I want to do that
programmatically so every time I watch
the video the video comes out faster and
through a little bit of research I found
out that there's the YouTube iframe
player API which is pretty great it
turns out you can send a ton of
different pieces of information to you
to a video that's embedded during
YouTube and the point here is that you
can you can send code you can examine
things dirty elements tab and so that
now we're actually gonna get to the
chrome parts so in case you didn't know
it turns out this is called a kebab menu
that's what I learned three recently or
making it like a skewer menu or meatball
menu I'm not sure so you can find more
tools developer tools
I usually hit command option I but
that's where you would find it and you
can paste in this code that I found on
Stack Overflow no seriously I
it's a JSON it's it's a command it sets
the playback rate so to you send the
message you post it to the iframe player
and I know you're all probably thinking
like yeah I've done this before it's
fine you come over here you paste in
your code and you play this video
actually let's refresh this page because
it's already played and now suddenly
this video he say hope you can tell
that's like moving faster than one
second at a time one thing that's
important to note here is that you can
see that this is actually searching for
a element that has the idea of player
and if you want to make sure that was
working you could come over here and see
indeed that there's an iframe here with
the idea of player one thing that I
really love doing is if you hit command
shift C I realize you can't see my hands
but hit command C and you can highlight
over any of these elements and then
select it from there so that's really
cool you know you can make videos play
faster if you do this with torsos video
she sounds like a chipmunk
but that's not good enough we you know
we want to come and say where that we're
watching at hundreds of times and so we
don't want to paste that code and every
time and so can we figure out how the
site is communicating with the server in
this case I was like being so e and like
going hahaha I can like go over to this
tree and like maybe I can edit this text
I can like go here and go like yes I've
watched it like a bajillion times I'm
great but you know you refresh the page
of course you know what the views are
not there and so there must be some sort
communication that's happening and
that's what the network tab is for you
can even come over here and you can
actually watch everything that's
happening so if we refresh this page
start over you can see a ton of
different things happening watching all
these scripts go through the videos
happening and so you might meet you
thinking like this is really complicated
but it turns out that you can you
actually filter by domain you know that
Swifty's is probably not sending a
request to youtube.com in order to track
of you
and so you can actually type here domain
in this case we can see actually I'm not
sure if you can see it but the domain is
my local host 127 0.0 0.0 0.1 and so
that actually filters out and takes away
all that YouTube off that double-click
and all that other stuff next we know
that there's some animations apparently
going on and some like left pad so we
know that we've we don't really care
about all of this stuff so we've got
some we know that we have xhr here and
what swing is that I someone asked me
what does xhr mean I could say oh let's
answer XML HTTP requests and if they ask
me anything else I'd be like Ajax I
don't know and that's I feel like I've
gone pretty far in life with just that
knowledge so anyway you you can click
here for xhr and that that's really
great because now you can filter out all
this chaos you can ignore it if you want
to look at the CSS you can actually
filter out your network requests so we
went down to two network requests from
out of like let's say 49 requests so
that's one really easy way to like
filter out and like drill down to like
the information that's really relevant
here and so now we can see that there
actually is a count request that's
happening so I mean we can investigate
that so from here we can click on this
we can read through like what's
happening there's some request headers
our user agent string and there's this
interesting ID here that's like looks
with randomly generated so maybe we care
about that you kind of store all this
information away in case it comes up in
the future and then we can see that the
response from the server is that there's
a true successful response I'm surprised
I haven't been checking in to see if
people are seeing the screen so I'll
keep moving all right so we open the
network tab we filtered oh and also I'm
glad I have the slides because there
reminds me of all the great things I
want to talk about so we come here to
the initiator column and this is really
cool I may have just found out about
this yesterday so that's really great
you can go here and see what stacktrace
led to this count endpoint happening so
if I go here I can see if there's
some sort of VM stuffed I heard that's
the next talks that's I'm excited for
the next one we can learn what's going
on here but we can pretend that that
doesn't exist for now there is record
view and update view count if I click
here I can see a bunch of stuff going on
I can also see that there is some code
here it's like checking for a current
time versus the duration of the video so
I can see maybe like 60% of the waitress
video is when we record that the user
has viewed the video so that's kind of
interesting we can like even test out
that assumption let's refresh this page
and I skip all the way to the end I've
met five views and now I'm at six years
so I've already like learned a little
bit just by checking out the code inside
of here and so we looked at the response
and request data and I was really afraid
that none of this would work so I took a
ton of screenshots in case I had to like
go back to the slides that's everything
we just saw so now we've seen that
there's a count request and maybe if we
send that count request over and over
again
we might be able to get some more of
these views so you come back over here
let's play this video and there's the
count endpoint one thing is really great
you can do is click here or play xhr and
that will just redo this request again
so now you can see that there is no
initiator column because I initiated it
from the menu and you can see that the
ID here is the same ID as before this is
the original request and this is the new
request but that the success is false
and so server's telling us that's not
going to count this as a few we can test
this if i refresh this page let's try
replaying it a bunch of times
I should see mmm like 10 views but when
i refresh the page I only get seven so
only the first request went through so
that's kind of mysterious I'm not sure
what's going on here and so the next
question might be like well but you know
there's that unique ID what does that
mean like does it have to be something
different every single time
and that's where a curl comes in curl is
a command-line tool that lets you make
get request and post across through HTTP
and all the other methods one thing that
I hate about Carl is that I never ever
get the syntax right there's all those
headers there's the new lines and all
that and it's just confusing so one
thing that's very great that you can do
here is I found out this you can copy
this exact request as a curl command and
then you don't have to do all that
formatting yourself so let's do some
curl and now like I can see I have all
these headers I have my data if I go
here and I say something like hello J's
conf that's a unique ID maybe it hasn't
been sent yet maybe I'll work and so if
I paste this in no it doesn't work it's
still false it was worth a shot though I
remember I had practiced this talk
recently and someone was like what if he
just changed the ID and so I wanted to
confirm that the ID does matter so we
know there's something going on here we
want to get that ID but we don't know
where it is so we want to send a valid
request
so let's debug this we know we can find
the code from here but what if we want
to get to the code before it actually
runs before that that Ajax request
happens so I can come over to sources I
was supposed to have that open and one
thing that's really great is you can set
your regular breakpoints just in at
lines of code but you can actually break
on on Ajax requests before they happen
you can break any time a request happens
and it turns out YouTube is constantly
making xhr requests and so it's actually
not that useful so delete that one but
we can break anytime the count happens
and I will say any time an ER L contains
the word count will just stop so let's
refresh the page and there is we no
doubt now that we're in this weird VM
code that we can ignore let's make this
a little bit bigger and when we look
through the stack trace we can
be careful and say okay well there's the
record view but you know if you're
updating the view count but there's an
ID eater
and so we can see if there's a variable
somewhere we know it's like somewhere in
our scope if I can see the scope oh it's
on the right thank you
thanks to Chrome so to scope is
somewhere in here for the ID it's a
global variable indeed and at this point
I may have just command F for the word
ID and realize I was at the top of this
file which is pretty interesting
let's see I'm trying to make this a bit
bigger for you so if i refresh this page
a bunch of times I can see that this ID
keeps changing and so like what you can
do is you can come over here to network
click on counters you can see it indeed
this response is coming through every
time every time I load the page I get a
new counter and so at that point you
know you know that you can you can
definitely download this file and parse
out that ID using a regular expression
which I will gloss over for now so this
ID here what happens if I copy it if I
steal it and I put it inside my curl
request
maybe I am done which maybe I'm done now
is the I kind of overall theme of this
talk so I put that new idea and I paste
it and I'm like it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen it's not gonna happen it's
just like so disappointing like
soul-crushing but now I know at least
that there's an ID that I can get but
there's something we're missing clearly
and at this point I will say this whole
thing I know I'm like squeezing into
like 30 minutes but it actually did take
me a couple of days like I got really
frustrated I'd put it away I'd talked to
some friends perk up and I just keep
coming back to it
and eventually after trying so many
different things I realized that there
was something going on with this with a
start endpoint and then I'm pretty much
oops let's restart this
I realize that is false so I noticed
that there was a start in fine I was
giving the same like style of response
as the count end point and I also
noticed that that break point is here so
let's press play so we're back in here
and I noticed that the start end point
has an ID in it and so it must be it
must be connecting it back to the count
somehow and so honestly I don't have a
good like intuition for how this
happened but I just decided that maybe I
should try running the start command and
then I should try running the count
command
I did try like a dozen other things but
I will give you the answer because we're
only here for half an hour so I have
this this curl command I'm gonna paste
out my this is the start end point you
can see it right here and I'm gonna try
refreshing this page so I can get a new
fresh ID I can go over to sources here
it is and I'm gonna paste it right here
and also right here so I've got this
start and you know okay so that one was
true that's good what if I come over
here and try the counts and it's true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I realized that that the climax is
just kind of like you try a lot of
things you debug a lot you read through
all of the code that you can find that
isn't minified and you eventually figure
out what's going on with the site and
then the next question is you know can
we automate the solution we know that we
got a unique ID we send a request to
start endpoint we send a request to the
account endpoint and if we repeat this
hopefully we should be able to get more
and more views I'm gonna do that thing
that Martha Stewart does where you know
she has her like oven where she makes
her turkey and then she puts it in and
she walks to her second oven and
suddenly there's another turkey and I've
never had two ovens in my life sometimes
I've had like one I've had like zero
ovens before but I have this great thing
called turkey pie so we're gonna send a
request you're just using the Python
request endpoint we have this regular
expression that just literally searches
for a string VAR ID equals such-and-such
thing and we're going to get the
counters endpoint and we're going to
then post to the start endpoint with the
token that we parsed out then we're
going to post to the count endpoint and
hopefully you will see a bunch of
successes so come on yes okay so we did
we just manually or automatically did
all the things that we were manually
doing with curl if I come back over to
the browser and refresh this page now I
have a hundred views so I can like run
this again and again I'm so glad I'm on
the local host because that would not
have worked over the Internet so how'd
it's a conference Wi-Fi so now I have
like 200 views I can keep running that
again I can even change the target
thousand but you get the idea
now I I've actually proven that I am the
greatest Taylor Swift fan I have more of
you say anyone I have more views than
it's like physically possible to watch
in one day so that's all great so the
last question you might be asking is how
do we prevent this from happening you
know we're all web developers here we
know that we we don't want people like
us to be playing with our sites
and so the first like I think most easy
thing to do is like run a CAPTCHA like
every time you watch a video or every
time you submit a form like say you want
to stop someone from automatically
buying your stuff you can make them fill
out a CAPTCHA one thing that is a
problem in this case is that you don't
want to make users for Kaptchuk every
time they play a music video now how
people really annoying you'd lose all of
your real fans um so you know there's
pros and cons so you want to be
thoughtful but when you would use a
CAPTCHA another thing you could do is
randomize the Dom I thought this was a
really clever idea you could you know we
had we all of this just hinged on the
idea that we could get the ID out of the
out of the files that we were
downloading and I was always in the same
place I was always far our ID equals
string if you changed out the variable
names or randomize them or you even like
dynamically generate those ideas maybe I
concatenate strings together all of that
would stop someone from just a regular
expression expression in out the IDS a
really tricky idea that Mahmut
co-workers gave me was that if you're
let's say you're you have a forum where
people are buying something rare like a
special t-shirt or something you could
have a hidden buy button inside of the
Dom that isn't showing to a user so that
it and you can randomize which bun comes
first so that if someone's trying to
traverse the Dom in order to find the
button then they would sometimes hit the
wrong button and that's how you'd know
if they were bahding or scripting I
think the easiest or the simplest thing
you can do actually is not to stop BOTS
from accessing your website but just let
them in and validate what kinds of
behavior is seeing and not a Melbourne
is really really familiar with this
because I learned that there it takes
about 10 hours to drive from Melbourne
to Sydney but if you speed there you can
get there in six hours and how's that go
why not just do it just just speed
through for six hours
and my friend says that told me that
they'll take a picture of you at one
point during this long drive and then at
the end they'll take another picture of
you and they'll compare those timestamps
and say there's no way you could have
made it there in the right time and so
there that's how to catch you for
speeding so you can do the same thing
there was no way I could have watched
200 let this video 200 times in so many
it's and so if you detect that you can
just flag the accounts that are doing
bad things one thing that's really
important to do with this is to not
alert the person who you believe is
botting you can just keep sending them
success equals true you can just keep
telling them that they're doing great if
they're scraping your website you can
start sending them like vaguely true but
also not real data and you know the
benefit is that you're you're not
tipping them off you're letting them
keep thinking that their solution is
working and at the end you don't have to
sell in tickets and so those are just
some like starting points for how you
figure out how to stop you from doing
this if you can make it so that someone
can't just keep sending posts and gets
in order to get to your website that's
probably enough to deter the most the I
guess most anyone but the most dedicated
fans so why haven't any in with me well
I didn't get saddle band I actually was
really afraid of that I thought like I
find all this work and on the day of I
thought I would just like get an email
saying you don't get tickets but they
didn't somehow they didn't realize that
I was watching this video way more times
than I could have I did get a high
priority position in the sale
the sad part is these tickets cost money
it costs like fifteen hundred dollars to
say at the front at the concert and I
was like not like at all prepared to do
that so I went to work I spent all these
hours doing this and then realized that
I didn't want those tickets after all
but I did get like the cheaper tickets
like you know kind of in the back oh
maybe I'll see her like from far away
like bring my binoculars
I got over a job so that was great
it's really great it was an internship
and I kind of want to be like what makes
you think I don't have a job man is it
the Taylor Swift I don't know maybe I
maybe I just like project I have too
much time on my hands
and I got to give this talk so that's
really great I'm really glad I got to
come to Australia and talk to you all
about chrome developer tools so just to
sum up we asked a ton of questions
during this talk we are thinking about
like can we watch the video faster how
how are we communicating what's going on
with the network tab how do we do this
again how do we make it repeatable how
do we find these tokens we were doing a
lot of debugging and we wrote some
scripts and so that's a lot of really
big questions IRA's that's like kind of
hard to remember but I think the thing
that you can walk away from this with is
like first of all you got all this like
concrete skills you know hopefully
you've learned something or at least one
thing about chrome developer tools that
you didn't know but the more important
thing is you know there's a spirit of
debugging where you're filtering out the
information that doesn't matter you're
you're figuring out which path to go
down
and you're also persevering like even if
it takes our history you know it's okay
you can try things over and over again
and you can keep asking questions and so
I want to say here is going to be
curious if you--if you want something to
happen and it's happening in the browser
you have the tools and those Stack
Overflow to make it happen yeah so thank
you here's all of the information
[Applause]
you